[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen nochmal und erlebte
sie sagten gerade frau merkel macht
sowieso was ich will da sitzt einer der
hat frau merkel gezeigt dass man sich
gegen sie durchsetzen kann
geht gleich schon zur sache er liegt da
sagt quatsch was der junge da erzählt im
fernsehen nein ich meinte diese
effizienz die sie mal da geht es um die
pflegedokumentation dass wir eine
personal quote brauchen da sind sie
einer meint wochen steht das nicht in
ihrem wahlprogramm
wir hätten es bei jamaika
die let ist gemacht oder anderen worten
darf also dass die fdp sich jetzt in
enormen masters für die pflege einsetzen
das ist mir auch eigentlich neu also ich
glaube auch dass die pflege jetzt nicht
so den ich dann die chancen sich einfach
mal neu vertraut zu machen mit sagen
okay aber sie haben ja gesagt auch in
diesem video was ich wahrscheinlich auch
gern wo sie mit diesen krankenpflegern
unterhalten haben die privaten können
vielleicht besser mit geld umgehen und
die sind vielleicht auch effizienter als
doch genau so haben sie es gesagt sie
haben gesagt vielleicht sind die
privaten vielleicht könnt ihr besser mit
geld umgehen genau so haben sie gesagt
jetzt möchte ich bitte das auch zu ende
führen
der größten alle tricks drauf
und der größte klinikkonzern in
deutschland helios zusammen mit
fresenius hat im jahr 2016 über 500
millionen euro gewinn erwirtschaftet bzw
erwirtschaftet heißt auf kosten der
pflegekräfte hat man einfach
wegrationalisiert und wenn man das mal
grob überschlägt und das kann eigentlich
jeder der was mit 3 satz schon mal zu
tun hatte dann sind das über 10.000
vollzeitstellen in der pflege 10.000
pflegekräfte die man dringend bräuchte
und wo landen diese 500 millionen euro
das wissen sie das weiß nicht um das
weiß eigentlich jeder das ist ein aktien
konzern die leiden haben ende bei
wenigen die sehr viel geld haben klar es
gibt auch renten fonds beispielsweise
die an solchen aktiengesellschaften
beteiligt sind aber es hat ganz viele
unternehmen man sich beteiligen muss und
das muss nicht im gesundheitswesen sein
dass meine meinung
ich verstehe ihre position wie oft dass
sie gerade bezug genommen haben mit mir
bei der pflege das war paradoxerweise
eine private einrichtung in die der wdr
plötzlich die mitarbeiter von einer
diakonie einrichtung geholt hat und ich
war plötzlich in der situation
ich musste die privat beschäftigten
gegen die von der diakonie sozusagen
verteidigung war der schiedsrichter acht
sehr talentierter junger mann schon mal
darüber nachgedacht in die politik zu
gehen
ach ja es ist also angebote eine
angebote so direkt nicht aber ich glaube
wenn man in die politik gehen will dann
muss man glaube ich auch manchmal gut
lügen können und mehr
[Applaus]
aber man
war
so verlassen können dass man am ende gar
nicht mehr versteht worum es eigentlich
auch das sehe ich anders
auch das sehe ich an man guckt wie
langsam politiker satz ist in verglichen
mit einem satz eines normal user können
das auch schon ganz gut
[Applaus]
und zwar ich glaube dass viele auch die
bundestag sitzen ich bin niemand der
sagt die arbeiten nicht und so ich weiß
dass ganz viel arbeit auch außerhalb des
bildes unsere stattfindet und politiker
häufig für uns ein stunden takt haben
ich bin da auch gar nicht so eingestellt
aber ich glaube dass gerade in der
pflege das problem ist dass viele
politiker absolut keine ahnung haben was
da abgeht aber wirklich
[Applaus]
das können wir auch den schönen tag noch
wenn ich nicht gern da vorsitzenden der
fdp mann aber also insofern kenne ich
aber ich biete ihnen an
sie begleiten mich einmal habe ich sie
und hab da auch nicht sofort
es ist ja nicht nach
was was definitiv bleibt von dem was sie
gemacht haben deswegen sie beide
menschen des jahres 2017
sie haben da den finger in eine wunde
gelegt von der mann tatsächlich sagen
muss dass das schweigt man von
politischer seite gerne so ein bisschen
tot insofern als man natürlich die wahre
dimension des problems die ja erst noch
kommen wird ganz nebenbei wenn dann die
die baby boomer generation dann
irgendwann mal so weit ist dass wir auf
pflege angewiesen sind den finger haben
sie wirklich in die wunde gelegt und das
ist das was sozusagen bleiben werte auf
der haben seite von alexander j
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]